-We first met in this building
in 2001.
You hosted my first "SNL",
which was not the most memorable
part of that.
It was also the first "SNL"
after 9/11,
which was a crazy "SNL" to host.
-Yes.
-Very burdensome.
I will say, from my side it was
lovely to have somebody come in
who was as sort of upbeat
and wonderful as you were.
-What you meant was as terrified
as you were.
-Yeah.
But I always felt bad for you,
because it was my --
It was our --
both of our first "SNLs."
I then, got to, like,
stick around
and do them as they got
farther away from 9/11.
But that's your only experience.
-And I waited 15 years
to come back.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
That was very smart.
-I got really freaked out.
-Yeah.
-It was a lot of pressure.
But I was really happy
to do it because --
you know Lorne
felt really strongly
that the city needed to laugh
and that people needed to know
that Americans
weren't going to be --
we weren't gonna sit down
and not let joy come back
into our lives.
-And it was lovely,
because that was --
I do feel like doing that show,
everyone said,
"I'm so glad the show is back."
And then like two weeks later
they were like,
"This show sucks.
It was only good in the '70s."
[ Laughter ]
And that's when I really knew --
-That's not true.
-That's when I knew
that it was really back,
that we were okay.
-You were amazing.
You were so good.
-I was not.
I was not fishing.
So, congratulations
on this film.
You had the premiere
the other night.
-Yes.
-Was this a book that you were
familiar with?
-Yes. I read this book when I
was 12 and I just loved it.
"A Wrinkle in Time."
And I read every book
in the series,
because I was also
a little bit of a nerd.
[ Laughter ]
And I just thought
it was magical.
It was -- I loved sci-fi
as a little girl,
and I didn't always find books
that had a girl
at the center of a sci-fi story.
So it was really exciting.
And my kids read the book, too,
in sixth grade.
-And were they excited when you
get cast in a book they've read?
-Yeah. They were really excited.
But I said to my son,
I said, well --
because I couldn't really
remember what the character was.
I said, "Well, Ava DuVernay just
called me
and asked me
if I'd be Mrs. Whatsit."
And he's like, "Mrs. Whatsit's
like a really, really old lady."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Really?"
So I called my agent and I go,
"She wants me to play like a --
I know, I mean, I'm over 40 in
Hollywood but, I mean, really?"
[ Laughter ]
Like a really old lady?
And so anyway,
she said, "No, no, no.
I want to reimagine it
as these incredible celestial
beings who are funny."
And I was like, "Oh. Okay, yeah.
Okay, cool."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, cool. Yeah, yeah.
-Good, 'cause I also saw myself
as more of a celestial being.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Less old lady.
Like, more like a star
fallen from the sky.
[ Laughter ]
-You have incredible co-stars.
Mindy Kaling is one of them,
who I adore
and she's just wonderful.
-Love Mindy.
-Just the best.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys!
Mindy Kaling, we would, like,
joke on the set because,
it was like me, Oprah,
and Mindy Kaling.
And, like, every time Mindy
would walk out the door,
she'd come back, she'd be like,
"Well, I re-wrote a script
and I also did a podcast
and I also wrote my new episode
of my new television show."
I was like, "I mean, what?"
And then Oprah would be
over there going, like,
"I have to do a board meeting
on the phone.
Can you guys be quiet?
I'm also finding a new C.E.O.
for Weight Watchers.
And also --"
And I was, like, "I got to step
up my game, you guys."
[ Laughter ]
-How was -- Well, you --
I mean, you have been
stepping up your game.
You're selling yourself short,
because you've been producing --
-Well, 'cause I've got to keep
up with Mindy and Oprah!
-Yeah, that's true.
That's a very unfair bar to set.
How but -- Real quick,
how is it to be around Oprah?
-It's amazing.
-Yeah.
-I can't actually believe they
paid me American dollars
to get to sit next to her
and learn every --
like, she's just --
I was scared, too.
Because, you know, sometimes you
meet your heroes
and they're not as awesome
as you want them to be.
She's better than I imagined.
-I once sat next to her
at a restaurant,
and I so wanted to go over
and say hi,
but then I also thought,
I think Oprah more than anyone
deserves a quiet meal.
And then I shifted from not only
was I not gonna say hi,
but if anyone approached the
table I'd take a swing at them.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "You leave this woman
alone!"
-"She's an American treasure!"
-"She's done so much for you!"
-Oh, see, I go the other way and
go, "Want to be best friends?"
-Oh, right.
Well, that would work.
-"I'm really fun at parties."
[ Laughter ]
-But again, you are -- you also
have been so prolific.
You've been producing shows.
You produced "Big Little Lies."
Congratulations.
-Yes. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know -- Obviously this is
one of those shows
that you can't talk
too much about,
but certainly season two has
some very exciting casting news.
-So, y'all,
we're starting next Friday
on "Big Little Lies" two.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't believe it.
And not only do we have
every cast member coming back,
but also Meryl Streep
is joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is that like?
What is the moment
where you get Meryl Streep
to agree to do your show?
-Well, she sent an e-mail
to Nicole and I.
And it said, "Okay, I read
the part and I love it
and I'm going to do it."
And I, like, dropped the phone.
Like, mike drop,
but I phone-dropped.
And I was like --
and then I called Nicole and I
was like, "Is this real life?
Like, is this really happening?"
And then I got off the phone
with Nicole
and I, like, hugged myself
gently for a minute.
[ Laughter ]
And said,
"This is really happening.
You're really working with
Meryl Streep."
And then I called the writer
and go,
"You better write me good scenes
with Meryl Streep!"
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think Meryl Streep,
historically,
every time she said,
"I'll do the part"
has then -- hears a phone
hit the ground?
[ Laughter ]
Like, that's just
what she goes through.
-Or, like, just somebody falling
over like --
[ Light laughter ]
-She says,
"I have some news for you,
but I want to make sure
you're near a hospital."
-Yeah.
"Are you sitting down?"
-Well, congratulations on that.
I am so excited to watch it.
Congrats on the movie
and it's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Thanks for being here.
-So nice to see you.